can we talk about the show dark know the
nightmare because we ever talked about
the nightmare that happened a couple of
weeks ago with with Remy yeah where is
what happened he's here yes Remy was run
oh he's he's on the our God remembers on
the little green stool outside oh can
you open that door Bryce or somebody
Bryce okay let's see I got it so you
know about Remy though yeah the dog okay
so she does she goes well how'd you find
it
kalila goes I'm Remy I want a foster
animals I'm like I'm cool with that what
does that mean
well we and because of the fires one
more the big fire is that happened the
shelters were overflowing shelters are
overflowing and and kalila like we gotta
help save an animal so um she sent me a
photo of a cute white dog
it was a year old and imma get it we
love it get it right I get it and then I
show up at the house and we got Henry
Fonda over here you got a [ __ ] old gum
gum toothless grouchy [ __ ] he was at
first he's sweet now and it hated me
well you know it you oh you know his
last owner was a guy with mental
disabilities a boy a retiree
yeah you've mentally handicapped and he
abused this little guy what do you do I
don't know man
but basically he got returned because
the mother of the this man said that he
was not able to properly care for Remmy
and I don't know what that meant but I'm
assuming because Remmy is not a fan
initially of men yeah yeah he's very
tentative but he loves females yeah and
I wasn't a fan of Remy in the beginning
like this old Henry Fonda should and um
but I grew to love it I love this guy
now well tell me what about what
happened was this soap Lila's Ike
I don't want to talk I don't want to
talk bad about anybody so we're not
gonna name any names all right we met
somebody at a park it didn't work out it
just didn't feel right
yeah their dog didn't get along and then
the next day she goes why you know I'm I
know somebody through Instagram that's
that you know someone contacted me and
she was showing interest in Remy right
so um we I'm gonna try to tiptoe without
naming names and being specific they
don't listen to podcasts they don't know
okay his name is you're a nice piece
they're a nice guy nice guy nice girl
and we also knew similar people Oh same
circle same circle right so we brought
Remy over there and the dude is cool
smoke pot that's not a bad thing and
wait so we leave Remy there yes so they
and they go we like Remy they really
wanted man the rent and the Remy on the
other dog seemed like they were getting
along and then um the next day this is
what happened what happened the next
morning I got a text saying your dog
Remy was found by this woman Courtney so
and so please call so basically he was
found outside someone took him to the
vet and microchipped him and I got the
automated text saying but those people
that I gave Remy to and never contacted
me and said they know they lost him see
you know what I mean yeah so I could
guess where he was rolling up walking
down Sunset Boulevard all the way down
there yeah yeah he's really walking on
Sunset Boulevard this little guy right
going where's Carla
yes he let me say something I have never
seen a dog so in love with another human
like this like that
I mean it's pure love and that's who he
left the house trying to find her I
guarantee it
that's in your head you don't believe it
I believe that 100% yeah so basically I
went to go pick up Remy and I texted
them and I said hey I have Remy oh sorry
we didn't want to alert you or scare you
we were gonna try and find him
our selves and we but we want him back
yeah yeah so that I got now she's like
no way he's a dog right so she says no
way and like no no no way but then I
wrote them and I was like look I think
this is this is a sign from the cosmos
that Remmy needs to be with me a while
longer so the answer is no and they both
the the chick and then the husband who
were really really nice people were like
look give us another chance we really
love it I'm the one that convinced
kalila I go you have to give them you
have to give them a know I read the text
you showed me the tech guys and what did
say what did you say Steve well I'm like
dude that's incompetence right there you
said don't give the dog back and we all
said that Jessica well you know you're
you're you're forgetting a big factor
the dude that let it like cuz the dude
Remy was in the yard and what was it
dude dude he was rolling too I don't
know that he was he was [ __ ] weed
paying attention yeah he was like dude
let's ruin a blonde or something and
then the dog he wasn't paying it you got
to be so attentive with the animals I
know it Kirby
he's Kirby has gotten lost yeah yeah we
you know we have to be so aware you have
to be aware of with your animals
actually dudes especially when you first
have a dog because it's so unfamiliar
with its surroundings and it's afraid
and doesn't know you well so it's gonna
want to bolt what it's exploring the
yard right you have to pay attention
anyway because because this guy I work
with this guy's brother on something oh
right so in my head I'm like we gotta
give him the shot Remy was freaked out
yeah and so I I said tell claw go you
know it's human kindness to forgive and
to give people a second chance and I
believe and Jessica you believe me oh
yeah yeah but dude they wrote a whole
essay dude like yeah and so she comes
over so you know she comes over the girl
right she meets sees Remy again you see
her fixing up again picks him up again
and we're like by Remy Remy we gave him
a chance but now we think Remy's found
his family we're giving a second chance
the same people it's 5:00 in the morning
now the next morning oh no I'm being
real this is real 5:00 in the morning X
morning I'm sleeping and I don't know
how I woke up but I hear iPads and
phones get going off
ding-ding you know like things are going
on thank you
sound effect yes good and I was scrawny
and I looked at my iPad and I read
something on it and it said something
about Remy but I'm like oh okay and I
went back asleep and then Claudia I
woken up and she's like what's going on
I got read me something she looks at her
phone and I hear silence I thought
product back asleep and she's reading
something a nice career she goes oh [ __ ]
he's gone again scream I scream they
like him again yeah way again the same
people dude the same way four months to
lose him like that soon I would be so
very shameful to even text you yeah yeah
so we wait no guys I wouldn't I couldn't
get on the phone just so angry was she
was so angry she's like you talk to him
cuz you I was angry at him I'd buy the
night I saw yeah I was responsible
I grow what's up dude I'm being we can
work this out you gotta work this early
an [ __ ] but being trying to be nice
but not so tell me exactly what happened
do it exactly what happened we're on the
same team right now bro yeah yeah and
and he goes well yeah I don't know cheat
me my dad rebuilt this fancy said bull
somebody said that smoking a joint right
rebuilt the fence was [ __ ] with weed
again and I don't know we just he left
right and then and then now I haven't
sighs that was what I was going to sleep
that's when I sleep that's your bad
right something like I guess we got to
go find out yeah we drove to West
Hollywood he called you made flyers yeah
we made thousands of flyers eyes Jessica
flew drives down sister came out Jessica
came out we had was gonna wake you up
alright
you know that's good right good here
there were 50 people looking for this
dog I was all I alerted all of what
Holloway looking oh yeah yeah yeah we
saw them better view no we saw them a
block away remember and I go and she
goes that's the guy yeah and he's like
you know putting something off a flyer
is bad for the
how do you say face though how do you
really say thank you guys like come on
my question is I mean do these things
happen or was it neglect like my I have
no idea it could be really bad luck to
it would just be bad luck cuz I really
don't like no I don't I don't believe
I'm not buying that I'm not buying that
so do you think that it was a sign from
the cosmos that he was that I shouldn't
have given him back the second time I'll
tell you this much if they were to get
another doctor price gave again if they
wanted it you know they got a different
dog the same [ __ ] would have happened I
think they're incompetent you know
they're not they're not no they're not
fit to be dog owners at this moment they
already have a dog now they lose this
little guy my believe is it this guy
can't jump I know you told me this guy
jumped over a big-ass fence near you
this dog I'm not this is I really
believe this this dog has been abused
his whole life okay he he meets kalila
who's a gentle animal whisperer true
she's a cherub of animals she really is
she's drawn she's the a beast lady right
and with tenderness in kind there yeah
that sounds weird and so look at the way
she holds him she the first day these
two met he was like finally love oh
right I've been searching for love for
so long and now I'm found in this nice
lady that Remy's voice yeah okay that's
pretty good and this other fat yellow
piece of [ __ ] lives you too but he's
cool he's cool right and then when he
was at the other person's house he said
lady you escaped in the second time same
thing happened any and look he got his
way now look at him so this is a he's
here not fostering this is can I just
say so she's even really weird no this
is why I'm still looking for a home so
if there's any listeners out there and
you like this dog and you want you
you want a magic grandpa yeah you want
to be a dog owner but also like lose him
the problem now the problem now though
is is that I genuinely have feelings for
the guy
so you're attached to him I was like you
know when we're in Arizona I was
thinking about Kobe I'm I can't wait to
see Kobe
[Laughter]
[Music]